it is now time to talk briefly about the
2020 election which starts today I have
said for basically for two years now
when people call when people say David
start talking about who you want to see
run in 2020 what do you think will
happen between the 2018 midterms in 2020
I've been hesitant because I wanted to
keep my eye on the most immediate
project which was the 2018 midterms
those are now behind us although we
still don't know the exact results from
all races and the reality is that 2020
is starting earlier than ever and it
starts today effectively not in the
literal sense but this is a long process
and it's a process that because of the
specifics of what's got what is going on
right now with the Trump administration
with what is understandably and
positively a huge insurgency huge rise
in the number of people participating in
politics there is a clamoring to start
sorting out 2020 now and one of the
analogies that I think really applies
here is that you can destroy things way
more quickly than you can build them and
what I mean by that is think about a
building for example imagine putting
together a building you've got to make
the plans and find the location
permitting excavation pouring the
foundation building up exterior walls
electrical and plumbing and internal
walls and then when you say it's time to
knock it down some dynamite or a few
wrecking balls can be brought in and in
a couple of hours you've undone what
could have taken in some cases years to
build and it's the exact same thing that
we have seen with our politics under
Donald Trump political alliances around
the world that were built on decade upon
decade of diplomacy and geopolitical
understanding have been destroyed very
very quickly
Donald Trump's tariffs which he created
on a whim in the sense that he started
to realize he was getting a reaction
from people on the campaign trail that
was positive putting in place
these tariffs that cause retaliatory
tariffs shake up the entire sort of
status quo of the economic relationships
of the United States with other
countries there's no undoing that now by
the same flip of a switch
we need negotiations we need meetings we
need cooperation agreements with other
countries it is going to take a long
time if at all under the Trump
administration and it may not happen
until later to undo the damage that he
so quickly did with those tariffs so we
do have to start talking about 2020 now
and I'm not doing horse race stuff I'm
not actually saying I'm now pretending
that we are in full 2020 election mode
but there are a few important things I
want to mention number one I believe
that Bernie Sanders is going to run for
president on the Democratic side I don't
want to say more than should be said
about it right now but there are people
I have spoken to personally who are in
positions where they can reliably talk
about this issue and there is a
significant group of these individuals
who are placed in a way that they could
say it with some certitude that Bernie
Sanders is going to be running for the
Democratic nomination for president in
2020 how that relates to whether other
progressives rather than just Democrats
run is something that needs to be
thought of already Bernie Sanders runs
and Elizabeth Warren runs what happens
is that what what are the dynamics of
that in the context of as the two most
progressive members of the Senate
comparing and contrasting them to a more
sort of establishment centrist figure
that's going to become an issue from
what I am told pretty soon pretty early
in 2019 that is going to be a thing that
we are going to be talking about and
discussing in 2020 either Donald Trump
will be running for re-election in which
case the goal is that we have two years
now to weaken him as much as possible
taking over the House of Representatives
is a good first step in achieving that
as long as and this is the risk
Democrats cannot allow themselves to be
framed as obstructionists for the next
two years because if Donald Trump is not
able to get anything done during the
next two years and has to explain that
to his base maybe he won't even have to
explain it but if he did Democrats are
going to get blamed for obstructing
because after all Democrats now control
the house now of course this ignores so
many political realities including that
even Republicans couldn't get on the
same page on so many issues during the
first two years of Donald Trump's first
term that they internally were
responsible for the lack of passage of I
mean look the Obamacare repeal didn't
fail because of Democratic
obstructionism even Republicans couldn't
get on the same page about how it is
that they wanted to repeal the
Affordable Care Act so we've got to
prepare and I hope that the Democrats
are doing this already they everything
we prevent them from doing we will be
blamed for obstructing and we've got to
have a way to deal with that the other
issue that's really important for 2020
you've got the presidential race is that
the 2020 Senate election is going to
have another roughly third of the Senate
up for re-election 33 seats are going to
be up plus a special election to fill
john mccain seat so this year we had 35
seats available in the senate via
elections there are going to be 33 plus
mccain seat in 2020
the numbers are way better for democrats
in 2020 than they were in 2018 this year
as I mentioned Republicans had these 42
senators that weren't up for re-election
so Republicans could have lost every
single race that they were running in
2018 in the Senate and still had 42
seats of course they didn't do that and
they're going to end up gaining anywhere
from two to four seats is what it looks
like as of right now and that's not all
it hasn't all been settled right now in
2020 my numbers might be slightly off
but you have incumbent Democrats
defending only 12 seats
and Republicans will have 21 seats plus
that Arizona special election for John
McCain's seat so there are going to be
much better numbers for Democrats in the
Senate in 2020 you're going to have
potentially 22 total Republican seats up
for grabs while Democrats will have to
defend only 12 so right away even if we
had you know in in our disappointment
about the blue wave not being as big as
we wanted it to be if we can achieve the
same sort of proportional results in the
Senate in 2020 that we achieved in 2018
2018 2020 rather could be absolutely
massive for Democrats in the Senate now
the big question that is going to
dictate how a lot of this stuff goes and
how a lot of these Senate races shape
shape up in in practice and sort of
their flavor and tone and tenor is going
to be who does run for the Democrats in
2020 on the one hand there are a lot of
in addition to Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren there are a lot of
really interesting possibilities and
this includes everything from and I'm
not saying I like this but it includes
everything from celebrities up through
to and including lower-level elected
officials who are very progressive
you've got the Castros from Texas you
have people talking about beta or Roark
you've got camel Harris's name being
thrown around I'm not saying I like or
dislike any of these individuals there's
going to be plenty of time for that but
the idea is that with this much time to
think about it and with such an
atrocious person in the Oval Office
Democrats should be able to do some
serious damage in 2020 if they actually
take the right approach and we're going
to be analyzing in depth exactly what
that approach would be now for people
who are going to write to me and say
David 2020 no no it is just way too
early to be talking about 2020 we can
wait that's fine but Trump 2020 starts
today he filed for reelection
within days of being inaugurated back in
2017 Trump yeah
sterday had his 2016 campaign manager
Corey Lewandowski with him as they took
in the midterm election results
Brad parse scale who's gonna be running
Trump's 2020 campaign was also with him
last night they are starting now they
get it we need to get it and in fact the
Brian Walsh was a president who's the
president of the pro Trump America first
action super PAC said yesterday the
reelect begins today it's all in and all
on the line their policies are horrible
their moral compasses don't work they
are liars they are projectors who do the
opposite of everything they say they're
going to do and say the others won't but
they get that it starts today the Trump
administration departures I would expect
to happen soon maybe even before the new
House and Senate are sworn in in January
they are building their sort of final
lineup for 2020 other than people who
are going to resign obviously they are
going to have that in place within the
next five to six months so I am asking
you now to commit to this two-year
project build the lead in that build the
control of the house take control of the
Senate
the numbers are in our favor but we've
got to do it and take over the White
House from president Trump it is
difficult to knock out incumbent
presidents even relatively unpopular
ones as we saw in 2004 with george w
bush let's all commit to this let's all
commit to voting as well and in that
spirit we want to continue to build the
david pakman show and continue these two
years so we did the minimum we had to do
we took the house back okay now that
opens up some doors for democrats for
the next two years now is when it is all
in because it's not just a senate
stacked against us which we probably
can't win and we can take over the house
we're talking about the Senate we're
talking about the presidency we're
talking about trying to get to 50% when
it comes to governorships
so we have launched a new coupon code it
this is 2020 all one word this is to
zero to zero that saves you 40% off of a
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership or WWN pakman.com it supports
the work that we are doing and we have
major plans probably too ambitious plans
we're never able to do everything we
plan on but with your support we can at
least do a bunch of it let's continue to
build these next two years are I am
feeling as invigorated as I've ever been
for an election cycle going into 2020
and it has begun and I want to hear from
you about it I am thrilled to tell you
that one of today's sponsors is simple
habit calm slash Pakman where you can go
and get a 7 day totally free trial of an
app that I use personally and love I've
talked to you before about the benefits
of meditation just simply sitting there
observing what it is that your mind
wants to do has been a great thing for
me we have so much evidence growing all
the time that this is just a good thing
for people to do and one of the best
tools you'll be able to find anywhere
online for guiding you through
meditation is simple habit it just won
the 2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app a very well deserved
award they have guided meditations by
some of the most respected mindfulness
experts from the East and West you can
choose from a huge selection of
five-minute meditations each designed
specifically for where you are or what
you're doing or the mood that you're in
they have meditations for following
asleep for when you're waking up for
your daily commute when you've just
gotten home from work
there are meditations specially crafted
to help people deal with anxiety or to
get focused before doing something
difficult and simple habit lets you keep
track of your progress by giving you
feedback about how much you're
meditating how many days in a row you've
been meditating it's a really
comprehensive and well put together
go check it out you can try it free for
seven days at simple habit calm slash
Pakman I've put a link underneath this
video